foreign
[Music]
has been out in cinemas for a few days
now in addition to the long running time
and the spectacular stunts it is above
all the ending that is causing a lot of
discussion therefore in this video we
take a more in-depth look at the ending
and reflect on the significance this has
for a possible fifth part that means
there's a high risk of spoilers for
everyone who has not seen the fourth
part in theaters yet at first the plot
is more or less familiar the protagonist
fights his way unerringly and brutally
through countless enemies becomes part
of a clan again and finally faces his
opponent Marquis De gramonte for a Final
Duel which should bring Jon back his
freedom in the process Jon and
Continental manager Winston are working
together once again after the ending of
part three initially suggested otherwise
and put fans on the wrong track Winston
also has every reason to support Jon
after all the Marquis blows up the
continental and kills Winston's
companion Sharon the Marquis continues
to live up to his bad reputation and
uses all he can to crush his enemy he is
not even afraid to send John's old
companion Kane after him by threatening
the life of the latter's daughter and
even after the honorable duel has
already been arranged the villain sends
out countless assassins so that he
doesn't have to confront our hero all by
himself the final battle is set in
picturesque Paris Jon was given the
choice of weapons to use and classically
opted for pistols the stinks are high
should Jon manage to win the Face-Off
against Marquis De Vermont he will be a
free man and will no longer be hunted by
the high table moreover in that case
Winston will be granted back control
over the Continental by the high table
however should he lose both he and
Winston will have to die as an appointed
Deputy Kane is forced to fight Jon on
behalf of the Marquis even though he is
far from keen on killing his friend at
first it seems as if Jon wants to
sacrifice himself for his old friend
which is why he doesn't fire a bullet at
Kane in the final gunfight the latter
hits the Baba Yaga on the side and
knocks him to the ground secure a
victory the Marquis ensures Kane of his
daughter's freedom and declares his
intention to take over in order to
finish Jon off at this part of the duel
well happens Jon still has his free
shot and shoots the completely caught
off guard villain and comes out as the
winner of The Duel the severely wounded
protagonist finally utters the name of
his beloved wife and ostensibly passes
away on the steps leading up to the
Sakura core even though you might have
suspected it it is hard to come to terms
with Jon's death after all the
professional Hitman has always been able
to miraculously survive after killing
hundreds of enemies in the last three
films knowing with sadness that Jon
might actually be dead this time we can
also see the Bowery King in Winston
standing by John's grave anyone who
thought the film was over after that
must not have waited for the
post-credits scene in fact reports are
piling up that many moviegoers didn't
expect one when they went to the movie
theater and thus left early at the very
end of the credits Akira the daughter of
John's friend shimatsu is seen running
towards the unsuspecting cane armed with
a knife whether she will be able to
carry out her revenge on her father's
murderer is left open The crucial
question after the end of the film is
clearly is Jon really dead although we
do see him draw his supposedly last
breath on the stairs there is no trace
of Jon's inanimate body after that first
of all there's less to argue against
than in favor of Jon actually being dead
for one thing it would be a good
conclusion to the story as the major
conflicts seem to have been resolved he
has won his final battle and is a free
agent already during the movie it is
prophecy that he will only find his
Peace and Freedom in death and that it
doesn't matter how many people he kills
his enemies will simply grow back like
the heads of a Hydra in the process he
even managed to do some good for others
Kane was spared and his daughter was
saved the same goes for Mr Nobody and
his dog in addition Winston gets his
status back and the Continental is to be
rebuilt the post-credits scene also
implies that future storylines could
revolve around other characters although
the name John Wick would then probably
be a bit inappropriate for the movies
two things in particular speak for Jon's
survival for one it may be unsatisfying
for many viewers that the high table
continues to persist as a relatively
faceless villain true our hero has
taking care of a few representatives and
fought for his freedom within the rules
of the table but at the end of the day
everything still happens at the mercy of
the criminal organization so even if
John were at peace now his companions
might still run into trouble at any time
the second reason is fairly ordinary
fans just want to see more John Wick
movies and Keanu Reeves has already made
it clear several times that he wants to
play the character for as long as the
audience wants him to moreover it
currently seems as though part 4 will be
the most successful of the franchise so
there's little reason for those
responsible to wrap up the John Wick
Saga in short the story of the movie
suggests that Jon did die however it is
quite likely that there will be more
stories involving the character
generally speaking there are still some
questions unanswered for example what
happens to Winston in the Bowery king
after John's death in fact the
Continental series with the popular
manager is currently in the works
however it will primarily function as a
prequel and will presumably only
marginally deal with the current film
series it's also unknown how they plan
to follow up on the post-credits scene
of part 4 a fifth installment in the
main series is by no means cast in stone
it's entirely possible that from now on
they will only focus on spin-offs Donnie
Yen as Kane in particular was so well
received by fans that many would surely
be interested in a continuation of his
story and even if that doesn't happen we
will have to wait a long time for a John
Wick 5. director Chad stachelski is
confirmed that the movie series with him
as director will be put on hold for the
time being the next spin-off from the
John Wick universe will be the feature
film ballerina which is scheduled for
release at the end of the year
[Music]
thank you